people want to govern themselves in this
part of Spain called Catalonia lots of
people want to secede from the rest of
Spain lawmakers in Catalonia declared
independence the vast majority of
Catalonians who voted in this referendum
supported that but Spanish authorities
didn't even want them to vote
the Spanish government deployed
thousands of police to stop the
independence referendum they assaulted
polling stations they beat senior
citizens and young people they just
wanted to vote Michel strong says parts
of countries should be allowed to secede
for years he's negotiated with officials
in Honduras trying to establish free
zones where taxes would be low and rules
simple five years ago he told me we're
close to a deal who suckered me years
ago this was about to happen in Honduras
it happens at the face of government and
the face of government is slow we've got
good news but until it's done it's not
done this is a drawing of what a free
zone might look like if it's approved it
would show the world and the rest of
Honduras that with simple rules and low
taxes people could prosper the way
they've prospered in places like Hong
Kong and Singapore Hong Kong and
Singapore were two of the poorest
jurisdictions of the world in 1960 now
they're two of the richest one of the
most exciting places in the world Hong
Kong they prospered because they were
able to govern themselves and ignore
burdensome rules imposed by their parent
country however most people around the
world are not free to try those
experiments most of the world's 7
billion human beings are stuck in nation
states that are de facto prisons we need
to allow for a lot more bits of good
government to pop up and to liberate all
of these billions of people from
terrible governments
these Kurdish people want independence
from Iraq for years they were persecuted
by other ethnic groups and most recently
by Isis in response the Kurds formed
their own army defended their territory
and then helped drive Isis out of Iraq
now the Kurds want to secede from Iraq
but no other government will support
them the United States says it would
disrupt the region most leaders are
afraid they'd have secession movements
all over the place and right and they
might
some left-wing California it's hate
Donald Trump so much they want
California to secede from the United
States
[Music]
their campaign videos show they're naive
goals California can be silly and stupid
but we need lots of experiments in it's
funny in the world of science we believe
in freedom to experiment now we need to
go to the world of government and
believe in freedom to experiment if
California was independent and had to
compete with rest the United States it
would have to up his it's game and
conversely the US might have to up its
game cultural wars are bitter and
vicious and if Alabama wants to do
Alabama's culture and San Francisco
wants to do is San Francisco's culture I
say let them go their own direction let
people be let people be what a concept
you